tourists heading to the ferry outside
Athens escaping a city that's so hot the
Acropolis had to be temporarily closed
everyone now heeding the warnings to be
careful we're trying to be smart and not
be out during the middle of the day
trying to stay in the shade as much as
possible so a lot of strategic walking
walking next to walls we take lots of
breaks if we need to go back to the
hotel shower change clothes lots of iced
coffees this is true only for forest
fires further south of the capital and
firefighter Nicos lebronos is less
concerned with tourists than he is with
new wildfires that are starting to burn
he and his crew haunted by the deadly
Blazers of 2021 that destroyed homes and
forests the climate was that of these
days
very warm very dry
and I want to to play not to have the
same situation
in Croatia they have not been lucky this
is the aftermath of Ablaze on the
dalmatian Coast a consequence of heat
wind and dry vegetation
beyond the immediate emergency that
often comes with extreme heat there's
another arguably bigger problem and
that's The Economic Consequences when
it's this hot for this long people are
far less productive and those who are
usually outside can struggle to work at
all
at darkiza marina for example the
fishermen are suffering
people have been told to avoid the heat
if they can and it's bad for business
the fish doesn't stand at the Heat
we have it's too late already the people
are not coming to buy the fish and we
have to live because the heat is too
much even for us in Greece it is a stark
recognition of the impacts of climate
change
now there are only two seasons Dimitri's
forecast says just summer and winter
there is no in between
the temperature has changed and the
change in the atmosphere is very big
a traditional way of life made harder
struggling to adapt as the heat
continues to rise
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News in valkisa